Pet Sematary is a book that Stephen King
thought might be too horrific to publish
its adaptation in a terrifying film in
1989 further cemented his place among
the King Canon and now we have an
all-new adaptation but what about this
version of Pet Sematary sets it apart
but many Stephen King fans there are
non-scary books there are scary books
and then there's Pet Sematary the novel
follows the Creed family as they moved
to rural Maine so that the patriarch
Lewis can take a job as a head of the
University of Maine's medical service
their new house is beside a road
frequented by fast heavy trucks that
often claimed the lives of local pets as
a result a neighborhood children have
established a pet cemetery in the woods
complete with the misspelled sign that
makes up the book's title when his
daughter Ellie's cat Church is run over
and killed Lewis and his neighbor Jed
Crandall bury the cat near the cemetery
but Church soon returns to the Creed
family home however something's not
right about the resurrected family cat
just as Judd begins to regret bringing
the cat back to life another tragedy
strikes a family the Creed's youngest
son gage is hit by another speeding
truck and the Lewis shaken by grief and
his new understanding of the pet
cemetery begins to ponder the
unthinkable
technically the pet cemetery of the
novel's title isn't the actual
supernatural part of the story that
sonic goes to what judd calls the real
cemetery a burial ground sets up at the
back of the pet cemetery that furrow
your ground was built by the local
Native American tribe of the Micmacs
when Church dies Lewis chisels out a
hole for him in the burial ground John
explains that he once did the same thing
with his own dog spots who was also
never quite the same after coming back
this leads to judge lesson 4 Lewis
sometimes
the person you put up there a diversion
that comes back later in the novel King
reveals that the burial ground was at
some point used for bodies partially
consumed by cannibals and that a
legendary supernatural creature called
the Wendigo has made a home there judge
says the ground went sour and now
anything buried might come back as a
hostile shell of its former self of
course none of this stops Lewis after
his son is killed King first conceived
her pet sematary when he found himself
in a very similar situation to Lewis
creats he and his family moved to a
rural home near the University of Maine
with a similarly dangerous Road and
local pet cemetery his daughter's cat
was killed by one of the trucks and her
resulting grief over the incident helped
inspire him to ponder what might happen
if he could bring a loved one back as
king told Charlie Rose in a 1993
interview here's something that we don't
talk about people sometimes have kids
who die there are terrible things that
happen and sometimes the child will die
young by the time had finished the novel
King thought Pet Sematary was simply too
dark to publish he put the novel in a
drawer and believed it would never be
released to the public in his lifetime
however the book was ultimately pulled
out and submitted to finish out King's
contract with his former publisher
Doubleday it was a success and distill
among Kings most widely read and
celebrated books made all the more
infamous because of King's own
misgivings the 1980s were particularly
fertile time for King's works six years
after its publication Pet Sematary was
made into a film with king himself
providing the screenplay and insisting
that the movie be shot in his home state
of Maine the film was a box-office
success and has gone on to be revered as
one of the best Stephen King adaptations
in 1992 director Mary Lambert returned
to direct Pet Sematary to a film
following a different family and the
horrific experiences with the Mi'kmaq
burial ground
however the sequel is not as successful
as its predecessor and King successfully
lobbied the studio to have his name
removed from the project
[Music]
looks like Danny cut up in the year
since Lambert's film was released Pet
Sematary has retained its reputation as
one of Kings most frightening stories
it's not surprising that someone would
eventually want to make an updated film
adaptation word of a new version of Pet
Sematary first began to bubble up back
in 2010 when writer Matthew Greenberg
was attached to write the screenplay
Greenberg eventually fell by the wayside
and now only has a story credit on the
new film development on the project's
daughter bits until 2013 when director
Juan Carlos Fresnadillo best known for
28 weeks later was brought on to helm
the remake Fresnadillo also eventually
dropped out and development quieted
again then in 2017 directors Kevin
kölsch
and Dennis wittmeyer the team behind the
Hollywood horror film starry eyes were
hired to tackle the new adaptation
though the new film seems to be very
much in keeping with the spirits of
King's original novel there's one major
change in Pet Sematary that the
filmmakers have already revealed in the
second trailer for the film is revealed
that the Creed child who's killed and
resurrected is the older la notte Todd
the gauge the reveal sent a shock
through fans expecting another largely
faithful adaptation of the book but the
filmmakers have some very good reasons
for the change among them the simple
fact that an older and therefore larger
child is a bigger threat
plus much of the horror in the 1989 film
revolving around the resurrected gage
was done with a dull limiting what the
filmmakers could do if they tried to go
that route again as producer Lorenzo de
Bono Ventura put it it was an
opportunity to show the audience
something new he told Entertainment
Weekly trust me we were nervous about it
I feel this way about anything that you
remake or update if we gave you what you
had before we didn't do the subject
matter much good I'm very protective of
movies too well I want a new experience
each time and feel like filmmakers have
really thought about the choice such a
major deviation from pet cemeteries
original plot is bound to divide fans of
both the source material and the
original film on one hand that there are
purists who would argue that gages death
it's a natural progression of the story
as the most vulnerable member of the
Crede family his death is the most
tragic and his resurrection is therefore
the most horrifying on the other hand
that there are fans who are intrigued by
the choice and interested in seeing how
things take shape screenwriter Jeff
Bueller
mitad that even he took a little while
to come around to the idea I was like we
can't do this and then once it settles
once that initial Stephen King purest
shock settles and you start thinking
about the mechanics of writing the story
and how it would feel on film it all
started to feel more and more right it's
impossible to adapt to work like Pet
Sematary and not step on somebody's toes
so we just kind of picked one big toe to
step on and just left it at birth so
what did King think of the big change to
his story a calling to star Jason Clark
Stephen King didn't know an issue with
it throughout his career Stephen King
has built a fictional universe all his
own that expands to connect in ways both
small and large even his most
self-contained novels this is most overt
in his Dark Tower saga which deals with
the notion of a multiverse but even
other novels contain these kinds of
lateral references the original Pet
Sematary novel features references to
Cujo Salem's Lot and it's with the
television series Castle Rock throwing
out king Easter eggs left and right it
would make sense that the new film would
also have its own list of references for
King fans to sports don't expect them to
be too on-the-nose though with Myatt old
sci-fi some of our art directors were
like how about we have some signage and
ludlow that says like Danny Torrance
Realty no because he wouldn't have a
realtor office and Ludlow
Harry white wouldn't have a prom dress
shop because she's dead
every little Easter egg and there are a
lot of them you probably haven't caught
yet of things that could exist within
the world of Ludlow and the story you
can make a very scary very stylish and
very violent horror film that still
comes away with a pg-13 rating as some
filmmakers that's the way to go since I
can help the box office if teenagers are
able to see it for other filmmakers
though there's just no substitute for
pushing the horror all the way into the
rated-r territory for Pet Sematary that
was always going to be the right path in
some ways according to Deb on a Ventura
it felt like the only path he told
sci-fi having tousled with the ratings
board more than I'd care to admit but
you have a child in jeopardy which we
have throughout this story you're
automatically in our I'll say it this
way also we've never had a conversation
with the studio about it being pg-13 my
feeling about rating in general is I
think some movies really demand one or
the other in this case I think you let
it be what it is and so I would tend to
want it to be our Pet Sematary premiered
at South by Southwest this year making
it the second
rahama release of 2019 along with jordan
peels us to claim a key spots at one of
America's biggest and trendiest film
festivals that means that we can get an
immediate answer to the most important
new question of all is it scary
well according to those who saw it at
South by Southwest a pet cemetery is
most definitely a terrifying film
it's freaky as hell scared the crap out
of me
Megan Navarro of Bloody Disgusting wrote
that there's a level of danger that
wasn't present in the 89 adaptation the
changes are such a big departure from
the source material that is quite likely
to ruffle feathers of book purus but it
retains the core essence of kings themes
and it always works for the better and
the final act is so absolutely off the
rails bonkers but it's amazing that a
big studio release ever let it pass it's
freaking twisted you'll get the chance
to see how scary the film is for
yourself when it arrives in theaters on
April 5th check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]